At present,
what should someone choose who wants reasonable energy and economic policy,
more social balance,
a foreign policy that he relies on
diplomacy and peace and not on the military map.
Who has the feeling that the spectrum of
opinion in Germany has become much too narrow.
And who rebels against this authoritarian,
presumptuous style of politics,
where people,
where people are taught how to talk,
what they have to eat,
or how to heat them.
Now also so Who so this combination?
What should he choose?
He's got nothing And,
uh,
that's what we want to cover.
And that's why I think when you draw parallels to Weimar,
I see a different parallel.
So without this extreme economic crisis,
without theMassenarbeitslosigkeit,
those at the Nazis would never have come to power.
And if we don't finally,
uh,
change our controls politically,
if we don't set ourselves up politically
differently than is currently the case,
I'm afraid we'll also get such dramatic economic,
And then the danger of not only weimarization,
but also of such a possible,
i.e.,
frustration in the face of democracy,
that then completely different forces suddenly come to power.
It is then very large and I would like to prevent that.